[Music]
so there's a woman who goes into a
goodwill store love goodwill in 2018 in
texas i like this you could spend 14
bucks and get a grandfather clock yeah
you find some really good finds they
have dollar day sales dude
or or you don't have to get a
grandfather clock and then [ __ ] have
to move that thing into your house and
it's like all heavy and [ __ ] that's
really heavy that's good but it's 14
bucks yeah that's true you can't turn
out a good deal and then you hire the
movers that are a thousand dollars and
help you move the 14 thing in there dude
i'm trying to get a pinball machine
right now oh that's sick yeah and and
i'm like nikki where can i put this and
she's like you have to put it upstairs
and i'm like
i'm not [ __ ] moving out
what kind of pinball machine you're
trying to get like what's the theme
terminator
like there's this company called stern
and they do all these new ones and i'm
thinking about i haven't narrowed down
to a couple like there's an avengers one
there's a ninja turtles one on the side
don't know you're into pinball we should
go to the [ __ ] pinball i've been
let's go yeah i've been there too all
right can i tell you a secret yeah so
this is what you do you order the
pinball machine
you find out when it's gonna come to the
house
the day it comes to the house you leave
like two hours early and then you have
nikki answer the door hi oh my little
girl hands i can't do it one time like
geo got them to move like six couches up
the stairs jen got another little girl
hand she's big no but that nikki is
smaller that's true she's a little girl
handsome because if you have the minute
you have a dude there the dude's like oh
okay here's
a sign
but when a girl opens i can't do nothing
don't bring it up make nicki do an
accent
i can't do nothing in my little hands
put her in a wheelchair oh yeah
put her in the full body get the idea
in her veins have her hair just like
just rip out pieces of her hair yeah
yeah
i have stage four
i can't with my carpal tunnel
i can do messy you want to know you want
to know the best goodwill flip
every summer buy all of the snowboards
and winter stuff that you find at
goodwill sell it when winter rolls
around and you can make a lot of money
this is how you're worth 18 million
dollars that's garyvee dude yeah you
gotta start somewhere damn right it's
like a dollar store garyvee right
people get rid of seasonal [ __ ] all the
time at goodwill on the wrong season
snowboards is the biggest thing imagine
ryan
are you too bad and he's like so you're
wondering how i got all these snowboards
i read 29 books a day
ryan's a true hodler right there
all right so check it out so she goes to
a goodwill she picks this little guy up
this little bust wow all right that
looks expensive it's like 10 bucks that
[ __ ] looks like [ __ ] augustus or
something yeah oh man this is gonna be
worth like two million dollars some [ __ ]
this was this was
looted during world war ii from a
[ __ ] museum
it's authentic and it ended up at
[ __ ] goodwill in texas how
nobody knows let's go to goodwill right
now let's turn these [ __ ] cameras off
you know if this can go from italy to
texas then the people in detroit can
move you know
there it is
what's your excuse
this guy's not even alive yeah it's a
statue he's been stolen dude for the war
see i i would love something like this
for my house i'm decorating it right but
then all these bus are always off white
people yeah and it's just weird if a guy
have a white man it could be painted
yeah paint it
we could chisel the eyes
let me not make the eyes squintier
just get rid of the eyelid there's two
get rid of one eyelid
make it a single yeah you know what just
for you i'll do a portrait of myself and
marvel and give it to you yeah i'll put
it in my little yeah he just wants any
asian person yeah what iconic asian
person would you like to bust up your
mouth
michelle
you want smell charlie i'm fat ooh
chowing on fat but with sunglasses on
fast kind of cool and a bunch of doves
i'll get loud too daniel
we need something like oh you're [ __ ]
sunblue i want some little boo give me
some blue
eyebrows out here
give me a
that's true because all the modern ass
like asian likes like statues are all
[ __ ] communist dude you know i heard
the new dynasty warriors you could play
as him you could play his mound then you
dinosaur you know what's the problem
with if they did make uh old asian busts
they just all look racist
why i don't know the way they made the
man they made him look that way they
look like
he second guessed it he's like uh
the confidence of that answer you want
to be these asian kids
have you ever had a dream that you
that's true they look like they judge
mexican kids playing basketball at the
park and [ __ ] yeah you know arm's always
behind them they're all like you should
be doing your homework you know
how much how much was that bus worth
does it say
it's priceless dude it's so [ __ ] they
probably got a dollar dollar day sale
dude oh here look i just googled smiling
asian statues this is a nicer one
see that one hand's always behind bruh
hands always behind that's [ __ ] kim
jong-un and kim jong-un [ __ ] ill nice
guys nice guys from history
it's it's all copper too yeah really
that's good
kim song and kim jong-un actually any
asian statues in l.a bruce lee there's
well do you consider buddha there's
[ __ ] confucius
at the cal state l.a they have a huge
statue of recent asians yeah bruce lee
there's a daniel day kim said she made
that up you can't do a statue of someone
who's still alive right it's a bit weird
isn't it yeah there's uh there's uh
[ __ ] not kim jong-il um yeah bruce
lee at chinatown doing the [ __ ]
um with the nunchucks there's like a
famous japanese dude
that guy no he has like a i think he's
like a guy that smuggled a camera in the
internment camps and he took pictures of
everything
so he's in littleton
mr panasana well mr penis
[Laughter]
this was a 2000 year old sculpture of a
roman general
uh yeah like i said it's [ __ ]
priceless does she have to return it
she can't get rid of it why because it's
stolen she doesn't she she contacted an
auction home in london that confirmed it
was this old like first century or
statue and then they managed to find the
same head and a catalog of items that
were in a german museum that was stolen
during an attack in the 1920s and 1930s
like during the war so it's certified
and everything so maybe it was like an
american soldier that was like they took
it they're like i'm taking this home oh
yeah when they stormed whatever yeah
yeah you know how sometimes you go to a
bank you accidentally take their pen
yeah that's the same situation situation
actually took a bust
thousands of years later
how did it get it through customs you
know i don't know if they had customs
back there during the war well they were
bringing all kinds of [ __ ] up stuff
back like they're bringing back like all
kinds of nazi knives and [ __ ] oh the
hitler youth knife what's a nazi like
it's like nasi lemak but diff little
sharper
way sharper oh
in junior high his dad was uh in world
war ii he did the pacific theater
and um him and his buds collected a lot
of the japanese uh
officers swords their katanas so he
brought it in wow and i was looking at
it i'm all like this is rightfully my
ancestors can i buy it from you and he's
like let me think about that and i was
thinking oh [ __ ] i hope he [ __ ] has a
little bit of white guilt so he'll sell
it to me and then he was like nah that's
my dad's
and i'm like [ __ ] yeah that's just
priceless
he wouldn't sell it to me man but you
know what's funny though i went to a gun
show
and they they sell like old world war ii
relics and there was a ton of those
swords so apparently like they're very
common they're common they're just like
[ __ ] bayonets did you buy one
once you saw how comedy yeah i was like
that was junior high bro i wanna buy one
my grandpa has one from the [ __ ]
korean war dude
a sword yeah it's like on his wall and
[ __ ] has a [ __ ] dried blood on it
there's like a head of a korean man at
home yeah
put it on his mantel taxidermy of a
korean dude his name was he looked at me
wrong
[Laughter]
so no they were trying
so there's a the germans are trying
gonna try to take this thing back
the the terms are confidential so that
you know nothing it's funny but that
german museum stole it from [ __ ]
italy so like who's where's it supposed
to really
native americans should have their land
back i know russians imagine trying
classic
imagine finding out this thing you
bought for like 12 bucks is priceless
and you trying to give it back to the
[ __ ] museum what a nerd move yeah
yeah sell it she's probably getting
getting paid for it do you think so yeah
in that situation you rent you lease it
to museums
oh yeah they pay you like a thousand
that's a lot of the time what they do
it's like you don't give up ownership
but you're willing to store it in a
museum and you get paid like everything
in the getty is like that right yep a
lot of things aren't yeah she should
have made it to nfts and [ __ ] dude yeah
yeah exactly or do what they do with
sports jerseys which is so [ __ ] up but
they they like take a jersey that was
game used they cut it into a [ __ ]
2000 pieces and they put a little sliver
of it on a card and like it's a jersey
piece of a jersey
she should have just put a [ __ ] usb
port in it and then digitize the whole
bus
people do that stupid i have one of
those things i was in germany and i
bought a stein like the traditionally
made theme for for like beer and stuff
and it's like it's like uh
lined with like this metal so like when
the beer rolls off it tastes really good
even though i don't drink but then at
the top of it there's a little piece of
the berlin wall that's pretty cool
see i have that i have a piece of berlin
wall too i think everyone knows though
yeah
it's just a stone it's just a rock
yeah yeah
do you have anything cool
um i've art that i commissioned from my
house really malaysian artists wow so
sick i support my own people right
that's awesome like that make
caricatures of you like when you walk
down the street it's not me it's not
uncle rogers he's got a leap there but
the dick's still hanging out of it
it comes out the canvas to the street
artist please be generous when you make
my art yes
can we see some of the stuff yeah yeah
yeah i have pictures i don't know how
interesting it is for your audience
they'll love it yeah yeah yeah i will
custom art is cool man yeah it's only
one piece and what about non-customer
just buying it at ikea you know like all
the art that you can see at ikea like
you got that ikea dude like the [ __ ]
audrey hepburn
black and white
[ __ ] hey that's in my house
the golden gate bridge the golden yeah
or the one where the new york but only
the taxis are yellow
yeah yeah oh god oh the little kid in
the roses red he did it i got the
schindler's this one with the red jacket
but it's the london phone booth
i never thought of it as a schindler's
list
it was inspired by schindler's list
wasn't it there's only the red most
things in a way are the [ __ ] rope
bridge
dude yeah oh you gotta see this yeah
yeah that's my living room all right can
we uh yeah can we show that i don't know
you do it yeah it's the one with the big
dick i was outside no
i'll send it it's like a malaysian
coffee mug wow that's beautiful is it a
titari cup
i don't know i don't know if it's
showing up
this was commissions specifically for
you to own yeah i asked them to paint
something for me can i ask you how much
it costs will it inflate in price i
don't think so seven thousand dollars
how can we pump this painting man
do